While we get settled in are as usual gradual fashion.
I'm going to turn on,
uh,
one of the videos involving the last two CEOs of Polaroid.
And then after that we'll get into our normal routine.
Most people thought that the company needed to change,
um,
uh,
not because they thought it was in deep trouble or again,
you hear that in the back burning platform at the time,
but they thought that we needed to find the next big technology,
the next big idea when,
and they felt that it was out there someplace and we would invent it again.
The culture would,
would say,
we'll find it,
we'll invent it and we'll develop it and create better.
Um,
there was not a lot of thought partnering outside or using other people's
technology.
I think that's one of the panes probably convinced demise because
it was a member of the family died and that was tough.
Very tough for me and I know tougher,
a lot against,
um,
and almost get weepy about it at times.
Oh.
And to come to the conclusion
that that
train,
that that family was based on or that thought that the family was based on the
products and Dr Lands visions and all that,
who is going to change was like saying,
you know,
I'm terrible my analogies,
but,
um,
you know,
the family has got to change guys.
And that was tough.
That was very tough.
But,
um,
and I should have been more forced to.
That's fine.
You know,
I should have probably been,
oh,
it's going to change guys.
And if you can't get on the boat,
you know,
they'll get off in her instead of getting off next week.
You've got to get off the staff or,
no,
it clearly had,
uh,
a culture,
very talented people.
I'm very proud,
great competition.
Um,
highly intellectual,
very self sufficient,
can do,
uh,
well to work very hard.
Uh,
but a very entitled culture.
A very clear to me that they felt everyone felt entitled to.
Um,
they're things,
whether it be material or intellectual,
uh,
their role,
their department.
Uh,
so,
and also,
you know,
their benefits,
probably the richest benefits.
A Houston company,
which who are consultants compensation cause all the richest benefits they'd
ever seen in America.
Where are we spoiled?
Because we made large margins on film.
Yeah.
I think possibly that's,
you could argue that point.
We weren't,
I mean we had,
competition is an instant photography was competing constantly with conventional
photography.
Now if you call image making the field to call it [inaudible] photography,
if you narrow it down to insert the diary,
we had no competition until 19,
whatever it was,
76 or something like that and go that came in and then Fuji came in later.
Um,
did that make us complacent?
Is that the question?
MMM,
possibly.
MMM.
I never felt I was resting.
I always felt I had more on my plate that I could barely choke down.
We had an inferiority complex I think for a long time.
And that the quality of instant photography was not up to the quality of
conventional photography.
Um,
and we were spent hours,
hours and hours and millions and billions of dollars,
I guess almost focusing on,
uh,
getting closing that quality yet.
And we got pretty darn close to me.
And,
um,
I don't think we ever got par exactly,
but we got very close.
Did we spend too much time on it?
Well,
it's,
um,
how much time did we spend on trying to be good?
I don't know if you can put a value on it.
Maybe we did.
Dr Land was obsessed with it.
I became infection infected and was obsessed by spend a lot of my lifetime
trying to get that product on a level playing field.
I think every product has a life cycle.
Um,
I think every company has a lifecycle.
I think every human being has a lifecycle.
I think you have to recognize part of your job is as a CEO is to recognize where
you are in that life cycle and not where you wish to be.
I think
certain members of the board will surely interested in that.
We spend more of our energy and effort,
um,
covering the big marketing picture,
and not,
uh,
be solely influenced by the research and engineering kind of mentality.
They wanted us to pay attention more to what the customers were potentially
thinking about versus what we thought we had the grand idea and really all had
on now,
which I think historically
you might
too simplistically say that,
uh,
that was the origin of the company was more of the invention of the idea.
And then here it is customer.
Um,
versus what do you need out there and let us try to provide it to you.
We never,
I think that a full concurrence on what marketing you've met,
there were those that said,
well,
Gee,
you should have raised the price,
the film,
or cut the price of the film and you know,
price the film wasn't,
it wasn't gonna change it.
This was technological change.
This was not a marketing problem.
My price break at the time was under $50.
I thought that electronic image cameras had to get down to,
and I thought in 10 years they would get there and low and behold sake,
and just about 10 years for it to get there.
Um,
but I,
what'd you think of those guys?
Do I go?
Yeah.
Great.
We're going to see part of each slide.
Oh,
there we go.
Um,
we've got two cases this week.
Polaroid an Enron.
Uh,
there are two cases of dramatic success,
uh,
and then dramatic failure.
And in understanding capitalism,
think back to everything we've done so far.
The idea of abrupt change of equilibrium,
always being dislodged,
equilibrium always disrupted.
Uh,
the CARDIOTHORACIC systems case from the end of last week
was exactly such a story.
And Polaroid,
it's very much such a story.
Uh,
and Ron has a darker cache to it.
it entails,
uh,
the darker side of the human soul,
and we'll hear about that from a Jim Alexander,
uh,
who lived right through the middle of it on Wednesday.
This is a
tracing of the sales volume of Polaroid,
uh,
from 1957 until the firm's demise.
Uh,
one of the things you can,
that is of interest about this diagram is that the sales at death,
we're not dramatically below their all time peak.
So sales alone don't tell you enough to understand what happened.
Uh,
and this is the stock price
and this is what our stock price is about.
What's the,
what are the drivers?
I'm not asking for anything fancy here.
What are the drivers?
Yes,
back left.
Okay.
Expected future earnings,
uh,
along with some special sauce having to do with future strategy to maintain
share price
and how would interest rates play into this?
Wow.
Okay.
But just for those of us who are from Illinois,
uh,
spell it out a little at a time.
Who's from Illinois here?
I apologize.
I should have said Indiana.
I'm from there.
Okay.
Spell it out for us.
Oh,
a lower interest rate will yield a higher stock price because there'll be a west
of a trade off between a spending today and once you get tomorrow,
well,
sort of,
Jim,
do you want to help with that?
Uh,
they really are a projection of future cash flows to the shareholders that just,
that uh,
it used to be in the fifties,
sixties,
seventies dividends that where the bulk of those assumptions and today it's a,
it's a rare company that pays more than one or 2% dividend yield on that stock
price.
So really it's a projection of earnings encapsulated.
And when you look at that chart,
what you see is the typical problem with a lot of growth stocks and that is that
people buy onto a whole new paradigm and then extrapolate for decades.
Uh,
and you end up with a,
with a stock price that really bears no resemblance to a,
to current earnings
and an increase in interest rates.
How would that,
well that would uh,
an increase in all other things being equal and increasing and current interest
rates would lower the stock price because you'd have to be compensated for the,
the extra time value of money involved.
Right.
Sales.
This is a curb in red that we saw in the slide with a longterm debt super posed.
Sales reads on the left axis and depth leads reads on the right.
You think learn from that slide.
Okay.
You want to get this?
This is not a,
this is not a curve ball.
Okay.
Polaroid didn't have any debt until relatively recently in their lifecycle.
We pretty much started during the recession in the 1980s.
Right.
Was the debt likely to be important there toward the end?
Well,
yeah cause they filed for bankruptcy.
They did.
But what was the precise event that caused them to file it?
Sit in the queue.
The 10 Q filing in the case they might notice that takeover attempts?
No
back.
She cock
nine 11.
Uh,
not really.
It was related to nine 11.
What happened was they failed to make a scheduled payment on the death and that
triggered an avalanche of adverse results.
Drove the stock price close to zero.
And how does the firm ended up w what becomes of it?
It gets
sold,
sold to private equity.
And uh,
how much of its value do you think is of its peak value?
Is there at the end when it's sold to private equity?
You don't have to give me a number.
Just give me a lot of level.
I think last sold for 265 million at that end stage.
Yeah.
Now what was the value proposition?
I guess that's a hint.
What was the,
what would have caused you here is a Polaroid Pronto,
which hasn't made a picture in a lifetime.
Uh,
what would it cost?
I probably bought over the years,
three or four of these cameras.
I was never terrifically happy with them.
And have you ever owned one?
You're all way too young.
Almost all.
Tell us,
can we get a mic here?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
I got one as a birthday present and it was fun.
Novelty for like three months.
Uh Huh.
How,
how old were you?
Um,
I was eight.
Okay.
So you probably didn't happen independent account for buying Phil?
No.
Do you have any memory of how the film's price compared?
Well,
you didn't buy the camera?
No,
I didn't know anything about the pricing.
I just liked that it came out instant.
Okay.
Did anyone own one?
Edit,
edit,
age older than eight
back center?
Uh,
I had my grandmother's old one,
I was 11,
so I guess I can guess what you paid for the camera?
Yeah,
I mean it was a hand me down and I took like 10 pictures with it and that there
was no film left.
And I asked my mom if we could buy more and she was like,
no,
we're just going to get a disposable.
Okay.
So
the sales metaphor in the case,
anybody remember what,
what,
what analogy do they draw in the end?
The marketing strategy back there?
Yes.
Raise and boy and help us understand that.
Yeah.
Basically,
um,
you know,
a current instance,
a company that sells razors,
they're not making that much money on the actual price of the razor.
And you know,
some can argue they could even give that to you.
They can,
their profit really comes from that.
People have to buy blades in order to use the razor.
Okay,
great.
Can we think of any,
uh,
any other analogies in marketing strategies here in the alligator shirt,
printers and ink cartridges,
printers and cartridges.
You,
you've noticed that the printer itself or nothing and the cartridges cost your
first born child?
MMM.
Yeah.
And it,
it's not a bad strategy,
right?
Because most of us,
uh,
try to try to minimize the initial cash outlay when we buy something and then
you get hit in the back of the head by the maintenance of it.
And that was the strategy for Polaroid and it was in some periods a very
successful strategy.
Um,
what's the value proposition?
We get two dimensions here.
Not Very,
let's put them together.
Actually,
the quality dimension think this is 1948.
This is the first Polaroid camera on the retail market.
MMM.
It was much too,
I was nine at the time,
so I can empathize with you guys.
Uh,
but I was nowhere near rich enough to purchase a Polaroid land camera was a,
it was a very upscale,
fancy idea.
Uh,
but I did see pictures made with it and they were Sepia tone,
uh,
and muddy,
a very low contrast.
They were very bad compared with,
uh,
what could be produced by conventional photography.
And the,
the question was let's think about three kinds of consumers.
And this was largely a consumer product.
It had scientific and business applications in industrial applications,
but from lands point of view all the way along,
a real darling was the amateur photographer.
And
okay,
let's use indifference curves
in this space.
So we've got speed on the horizontal dimension and quality on the vertical
dimension.
And a person who says,
I'm indifferent between all these outcomes,
how would we describe that person's preference?
Sorry,
a professional if,
if he's indifferent to the speed.
Um,
Lincoln Lincoln's earnings quality.
I'm on April.
Go to what?
Kate,
you wave.
Oh,
hi.
It would be a professional or perfectionist,
right?
The model might be ansul Adams,
somebody who makes wonderful pictures and is willing to wait and is virtually in
different to the time dementia.
So that person is trying to climb in this direction.
Indifference curve difference club.
Yeah.
And this person,
Tim,
what's this person up to?
MMM,
they're trying to go out that way as fast as they can.
They're trying to get faster and faster pictures.
Yeah.
Cheap thrills.
Just like our friends back here when he was eight,
all they want is speed.
Well,
how many customers do you think fit either of these descriptions?
A few fit.
The first description,
a few fit,
the second description,
but most
are more like this.
They have a trade off,
which I've simplified with straight lines.
They probably would actually go in toward the origin like this.
Uh,
but these people want some combination of speed and quality and the central
drive,
uh,
for the Polaroid land camera from 1948 all the way to the end was to do as well
as possible in competing for the business of these people who were trading.
Uh,
the two dimensions,
uh,
the SX 70,
which was in some ways the high point of Polaroids history and in other ways,
the low point.
Anybody remember what was wrong with the SX 70
had battery problems it had.
Yeah.
How do you remember from the case how,
how the,
how the battery was related to the thing?
Okay.
Um,
I think Jim,
Jim Alexander and I are the only people here who ever,
ever experienced this.
The battery was included in the film pack and for the first couple of years they
made it.
About half the batteries were no good.
So if you spent a premium for the film pack and the battery wouldn't make the
camera run,
you are likely to be on an unhappy customer.
And they had a very high complaint rate about that.
Does anybody remember what they did to resolve the battery problem
back or yeah,
up here.
That's fine.
They might have punctured their own butteries.
Yeah,
they went into the battery manufacturing business,
which is as we'll see in a minute,
it's an integration move where they reduce their reliance on outside suppliers,
but create a whole set of new problems for themselves because it turns out it's
not for easy to manufacture batteries.
Well,
um,
the Polaroid SX 70 had gained enormous ground on conventional photography on the
quality dementia.
It was a lot better than the old Polaroid.
A buddy was still nobody drunk or sober.
Uh,
would argue that the picture is produced by the Polaroid SX 70.
We're as good as those produced by a conventional single single single,
what's it called?
Slr Single Lens Reflex,
35 millimeter camera with competent processing.
And so they were in a position where they had a deficit on the quality side,
which they never actually overcame.
They did better and better on picture quality,
but they never really got to where they matched conventional photography.
Uh,
so the,
I've drawn this so that they're on a higher indifference curve for this
particular consumer.
Then the conventional photography.
Uh,
but there were several problems lurking in that.
One of them.
How could this have happened without any improvement in either the film or the
camera?
On the conventional side,
the conventional photographic technology,
uh,
gained ground on the speed dimension and gained a lot of about
mmm.
With the advent of the one hour photo.
Okay.
So the one hour photo process
talk three days or five business days and brought it down to an error.
You dropped the film off,
go have a cup of coffee,
come back.
So that conventional photography with no internal improvement was closing the
speed gap and diminishing total demand for instant photography.
Um,
now there's a,
there's an incident at about this stage between Polaroid and Kodak neighboring.
Remember how that goes?
How had had Kodak played any part in Polaroids business?
Any cooperative part in the early years?
Sasha?
Yeah.
It pull up at Kodak was manufacturing for Polaroid and as it manufactured,
it learned the secret sauce
and then went into the business competing and competing effectively against
Polaroid with a tricked up reconfiguration of Polaroids technology.
Yeah.
And Polaroid responded with a washer.
Okay.
And they won the lawsuit.
They nonetheless got screw.
How could that be?
They win.
They get a $1 billion in damages or just a little short of $1 billion in
damages.
And yet Polaroids,
uh,
theft is all but lethal to them.
I think it took them a lot of time and effort to fight that case.
And when they finally got the reward,
it wasn't as much as they expected.
And then there was also this comment later that they kind of wished that Kodak
had been merged with Kodak and that hadn't even happened either because Kodak
did not had too much of an ego kind of do that either.
Both sides had a lot of ego.
Okay.
So that's,
that's you,
you got what was needed was an immediate intervention.
The case went on almost 15 years.
And Bob,
what was going on?
Kodak was eating into the competitive position occupied by Polaroid.
There's of course something else going on here and that's the emergence of
digital and digital photography with one important asterisk,
a trumped everything and it didn't stand still.
It traced a path and it's still on that path of virtually continuous
improvement.
A $200 digital camera now is as good as a $10,000 digital camera a decade ago.
And the
hands up if you use a digital camera.
Yeah,
everybody.
And on average,
my guess is that your digital cameras are about like that.
They're tiny.
Are they hard to work?
Do the batteries fail?
It's only one thing they don't do very well.
What's that?
Well,
they don't,
they actually do that better than conventional cameras,
but no camera does that very well.
What's my mother hates him?
Why would,
why would a 95 year old,
they don't,
they don't print her idea of a photo in something you hold in your hand and it's
not a real photo unless she can hold in their hand,
put it on the coffee table,
show it to her friends from the coffee table.
Right.
And Edwin land actually agreed with that and it was part of his,
uh,
part of his infatuation with the original Polaroid idea was that you make the
picture,
waive it for a minute until it dries and hand it to the people who are in the,
in the view.
No,
we're going to go back to the case in this informal way in just a minute,
but I'm going to talk about integration here because vertical integration is a
huge part of the Polaroid story and it's a part,
an important part of most,
uh,
corporate stories.
Vertical integration is the,
it,
the think of the dimension that starts with a raw product,
uh,
or coming out of a mine,
a sugar cane coming out of a field,
uh,
bananas coming out of a rain forest.
And then there is a progression toward a manufacturing or processing plant or
perhaps a series of manufacturing steps.
Uh,
then,
uh,
the distribution of the product to wholesalers and from wholesalers to retailers
and from retailers to the family picnic and a fully,
a full story of vertical integration looks like this.
Everything's in the corporate box from beginning to end.
The plus of that is obvious.
The trouble you might have with your suppliers is completely eliminated.
And the,
the ability to direct the details of every step,
uh,
is seemingly unlimited.
The downside there,
at least two obvious downsides.
One is a lot of companies are good at the front end without being good at the
backend.
So if they go from the front end,
from marketing or retail product all the way back to the first steps of its
production,
they may well screw up because it's just not what they do well.
Uh,
that's one difficulty.
Another difficulty is governance.
The management of a vertically integrated company is a very complicated process
and it tends,
as with the railroads we saw a week ago,
it tends to bloat the administrative apparatus,
make it have many dimensions from top to plant for uh,
and presents serious challenges.
Now that's only half the story.
The other half of vertical integration has to do with ideas.
There's a pair of the,
what I just talked about has to do with physical stuff,
material things.
There is also an intellectual track or ideational track,
which starts with dreams or ideas drawn on the back of a Napkin and then invoke
science and engineering and design and a marketing plan.
It is in effect the brains behind the lower box.
And with Polaroid you had a fully integrated company.
Now they didn't do mines and fields,
but you had a high degree of vertical integration in the ideas process and
almost as high a degree of integration in the material,
uh,
process.
So you end up there now.
Okay.
Why did this company fail?
Let's,
uh,
let's,
let's start with,
I've got a warm calls,
Ahmed.
Yeah,
I'm mad.
Why do you think the company failed
feel because of the capabilities and beliefs of the 1980s,
um,
that influenced their strategies?
Couldn't they were more technology driven and not market driven and reasons so
forth because of the senior management.
Okay.
That's in the chain.
Uh,
who was this Edwin Land Guy
who's a scientist?
He was a scientist.
When does he get his start as an inventor?
Does anybody remember from the case?
37,
pardon?
Oh,
Harvard College.
He's an undergraduate.
Any advance Polaroid filters.
Clever lab.
And he gets fixated I think on a certain view of how you do wonderful things and
it focuses on law,
costly time consuming research.
Uh,
Lindsay Jackson.
anything to add to that
about,
about land or about the causes of failure?
Oh,
I think did go off of,
uh,
land.
It was genius when he was able to do and he was so technology driven and he was
able to create such a successful company and at a certain point they did have
any competition or no real competition,
no direct competition.
And because the technology was what was driving them and proved to be
successful.
As the company grew older,
they got fixated on this idea that technology was with was what,
what was going to drive them.
So they were hesitant to change.
That's terrific.
So we combine an initial fixation on a very intellectualized r and d process,
which is very slow and mildly contemptuous of marketing cutting.
And we combine that with a wildly successful market product,
which was not designed by careful analysis of consumer indifference curves.
It was designed by Edwin Lands,
passion for this product.
He correctly guessed,
he lucked out.
He correctly guessed that it would command and enormous,
uh,
consumer market.
And sure enough it did.
So we've got a kind of path dependence story there and Ben Chu,
uh,
is there anything left to talk about on this or are we done
when Polaroid was developing its newer technologies,
it's important to realize that it's not that they were just stuck in the stone
age.
They were trying to develop date made forays into digital imagery.
Yeah.
But they still were
there,
were still shackled by the idea of making money with the razor blades,
a marketing strategy and really making money with putting on film.
Absolutely.
There's a wonderful quote toward the end of the page.
You guys read,
you remember it?
Yeah.
There's no need.
You don't need to,
I can tell it.
Ah,
here it is.
The uh,
um,
they're talking about what a wonderful,
and highly marketable device the digital camera is and the,
and this is a,
um,
a marketing person talking to a senior executive and the senior executives
responses.
Where's the film?
That's where the money is.
And of course there is no film and there is no money in film.
All the money is in the hardware.
And that was a hard idea for Polaroids,
top management to square with the initial model based based on razors and razor
blades.
The,
there's another idea that appears in,
this is one of the papers cited at the end of the,
the uh,
case.
There's another idea there that may be important and it's called bounded
rationality.
Hum.
If bounded rationality is a familiar concept,
okay,
we should stop.
And talk about it.
Uh,
Edwin land,
let's say his Iq was 290,
uh,
I,
since they divide by age,
I think he would've had to be about age three when it was measured for that to
be even logically possible.
But,
uh,
that's,
suppose he's the smartest guy in the world.
Uh,
he nonetheless thinks in bounded rationality.
And what that means is in order to get started thinking about something,
you have to explicitly or implicitly make a bunch of assumptions.
And those assumptions are typically arbitrary.
You can't examine every aspect of every assumption and ever get anything done.
Intellectually.
It's a true statement.
Uh,
and the task of managing a company is exceedingly complex and Edwin land and
Mack booth and the other people,
you have this very messy chart here that I took down from the,
the case.
Uh,
none of these senior executives was ultimately able to think in a way that was
effective because the bounding assumptions,
uh,
prohibited it.
And
what's so hard about this?
What would make it hard to run Polaroid for Ford Motor Company?
Uh,
what?
Yes,
because the assumptions,
all right.
To begin with was basically a research driven company and the assumptions that
they were making,
the benchmark was the [inaudible] research different company,
which in effect was not correct because as the markets were changing,
if SAP [inaudible] ability to be nimble and respond to the competition that was
there.
Okay,
great.
Is there,
is there an analogy and what happened to them in anything about the
CARDIOTHORACIC systems case?
What was the,
what I thought Karen did,
Sharon Sharon did a fabulous job of teaching it.
And why was that?
The two artery strategy force,
a cardiothoracic systems had to be abandoned.
Remember some of you said it.
Well it is this,
that the companies who were making the,
the devices for nonsurgical intervention,
the stamps and the little balloons and all that stuff were what kind of
companies,
huge well funded companies,
which we're not going to let somebody come in and take market share without
developing a new step of competitive device.
And one of the very hard things about running a big company is that you have to
be aware of all the other players out there who may be doing something to damage
your market.
They probably already been trying to damage your market.
They are probably not even thinking much about you,
but instead trying to develop their own bound Dively rational idea of their
company.
And in this case,
Polaroid was badly bitten both by,
uh,
a one hour film processing,
and by,
uh,
digitals.
And in the case of the one hour film processing,
it wasn't even the processors so much who were in competition with Polaroid,
but the conventional film people such as Kodak.
So
part of the story then is bounded rationality.
Part of it has to do with drawing the wrong wrong lessons from early success.
Part of it has to do with something totally irrational,
which was the commitment to a founder figure.
Those is it generally the case that Brennan engineers run huge companies which,
uh,
produce the product based on their ideas.
So generally it's not generally the case.
I mean we can all name cases,
but in general,
the engineers who create devices are forced out of top management and replaced
by people who are general managers.
And that's what happened.
That's what happened to Polaroid.
But it happened too late.
It happened much to right now,
if you were going to save Polaroid,
let's say in the 1980s,
let's suppose you are Mac booth and it's your task to give this company the best
chance of preserving its value going into the future,
what would you do?
Or what they did do was a hell of a lot of r and D on a long string of projects
which fail right from up.
Some of them were artistic or engineering successes,
but none of them were economic successes.
Polar vision was a disaster.
Helio's was a,
uh,
was actually a really good product,
but they didn't manage to recoup their investment.
Uh,
what would you have done if you're,
can we have the mic?
I'm about to cold call you.
You're ready?
Okay.
I'm actually visiting.
Well,
I'm going to cold call you anyway.
The nice thing is you don't have anything at risk.
Okay,
well you didn't read the case,
so that's unfair.
Um,
are you okay,
go ahead.
Uh,
what my tube done to save this company?
I really do agree with,
with boots side.
He said that he would have probably merged with Fuji and kind of use the best
aspects of both cause Fuji was moving forward hopefully in digital and they were
still kind of doing instant photography because one of the things that they were
still,
I think fixated upon was into photography,
what the founder founded.
So they are,
it was that kind of cult and they weren't really moving on towards other things
and like improving on other things.
Right.
Okay.
So a merger prompt,
a merger might well have been the best place.
Now.
Why?
Why would it,
what would make it hard to do?
I think it's the culture of the company,
um,
that they wouldn't,
it's a whole ego trip thing.
They were really proud of what they had achieved in the front row integration
and was part of the reason they were so proud of it.
Okay.
So part of it is culture.
I think that depth of theirs would weaken their bargaining position.
Great.
Um,
yes.
Yup.
Other than a module company.
But I think Paul Right.
Could have done something in the lines of what IBM is doing now.
Become a completely research based company,
cut off their marketing out the consumer processes and just research for Foodie
research for conduct new research designs for other companies who are in the
consumer field.
So cut diamond on.
Okay.
So that may,
that might actually,
that makes a certain kind of sense.
Talk a little more in defend the idea.
What
uh,
because at the end of the day,
the whole company culture was driven,
I was driven towards cutting edge research a lot of the successful products for,
because they were able to invent and create products that were successful on
lines of not success in marketing box,
not successful marketing strategies,
but they were able to create products which were ahead of the curve in terms of
technology.
So since the whole market,
the industry was moving towards the digital platform,
perhaps they could become leaders of developing these technologies,
which will improve digital products in the future.
Okay.
That's a very interesting suggestion.
Yes.
That the merger wouldn't go well because of the vertical integration that,
um,
that Polaroid had in place.
They had huge facilities and machines designed for peak times of sales and,
um,
these high fixed costs would have been a big problem for Kodak,
so I think that would merge with them.
Hi.
Um,
that might well be,
I mean,
they might've,
it might've liquidated those two private equity and kept intact.
Morales,
well,
I think there were specialized on the films of Polaroid.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
let's turn to an run now.
Enron is another innovation company.
Uh,
Jim,
can you come up for just a second?
I didn't warn him about this.
Uh,
Jim as,
as I said to those of you who were here at the beginning of shopping period,
uh,
Jim was chief financial officer of Enron global power and pipeline and saw the
process from the beginning.
He came from a,
a long career in investment banking before that,
um,
culture of innovation at Enron.
Was it important from day one when you arrived there as a consultant?
Yes,
it was.
There was a culture of innovation,
uh,
that was impressed upon the organization by kind of lay,
because he was trying to avoid the mindset that was typical of natural gas
pipelines at the time,
which is very much a monopoly rate based rate of return,
uh,
doesn't matter to make any money type of mindset.
And he went way overboard and reversing that.
Okay.
And what was Ken lay or famous manager and,
uh,
was Enron receiving prizes,
for example,
from the Harvard business school as the best run company in the country?
Um,
yeah,
so I've always thought that a,
well,
Jim is a graduate of Yale College at HBS,
so we've website here.
One of the things I've always thought people ought to do though,
in terms of looking at industry industries,
an imminent decline is,
is look at plaudits from HBS and the percent of graduates from HBS going to a
given industry.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the case,
for Wednesday is a innovation corrupted,
it's an HBS case.
It was in that packet of three,
which you got a week ago.
Uh,
please read it with care.
Jim and I will do this.
Uh,
uh,
interogate Tivoli out.
We'll sit together and talk it through and turn to you intermittently for help
in solving Enron's dilemmas.